bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy recordaremos al genio al
maestro al visionario compositor y
bandoneonista argentino astor piazzolla
a propósito de los 100 años de su
natalicio
[Música]
astor piazzolla nació un 11 de marzo de
1921 en mar del plata argentina a la
edad de 4 años se mudó a nueva york
junto a su padre vicente solá y su madre
assunta manet y en nueva york se
instalaron en el bajo manhattan
específicamente en little italy el
barrio italiano su infancia estuvo
influenciada por el gusto musical de su
padre el tango quien se deleitaba con
artistas como carlos gardel y julio de
caro de manera que recibió un bandoneón
como regalo paterno pero en nueva york
no se enseñaba tango así que sus
primeros estudios fueron de música
clásica de bach de beethoven de hecho
pan
el gusto de su padre vicente por la
música de gardel hizo que lo conocieran
en nueva york y que en 1934 el joven
astor participará en la película 'el día
que me quieras' protagonizada por el
mismo gardel dos semanas antes de la
muerte de gardel en el trágico accidente
aéreo de medellín de 1935 el músico
había invitado a astor piazzolla que lo
acompañará de gira pero sus padres se
negaron porque apenas tenía 14 años
bromeando años después que a solá dijo
que de haber realizado el viaje no
habría tocado el bandoneón sino el arpa
a la edad de 16 años que a solá regresó
a su ciudad de origen mar del plata- y
un tiempo después se instaló en buenos
aires su ingreso a las filas del tango
fue como bandoneonista y arreglista en
la orquesta de aníbal troilo uno de sus
primeros mentores que a solá comenzó a
introducir elementos sinfónicos al tango
de troilo que no cayeron del todo bien
de modo que abandonó su orquesta para
fundar la suya propia en 1946 lo había
dicho el propio piazzolla en la
argentina se puede cambiar todo
pese a firmar lo que asó la modelo el
tango a su manera para muchos su
orquesta estaba adelantada a su tiempo
era una música del futuro
[Música]
tradicionalmente el tango argentino es
una música popular que se baila pero a
piazzolla no le gustaba el baile decía
que el tango era para escucharlo y su
concepto lo siguió perfeccionando al
tomar clases con el maestro alberto
ginastera y luego en la década de 1950
con la compositora francesa
nadia boulanger su paso por parís le
abrió los ojos descubrió asombrado que
los músicos de jazz y de swing
disfrutaban en el escenario con sus
improvisaciones mientras que la
solemnidad y la monotonía de los músicos
de tango les recordaban los funerales en
1956 ya sola conformó el octeto de
buenos aires esta era una música para
escuchar con dos violines un chelo un
contrabajo un bajo una guitarra
eléctrica un piano y por supuesto su
bandoneón en 1958 regresó por dos años a
nueva york donde se vio influenciado por
el jazz los solos de improvisación y la
música de charlie parker a quien
admiraba este nuevo paso por la gran
manzana
para formar su famoso quinteto un grupo
de músicos en que cada integrante era
capaz de interpretar un solo de su
instrumento en 1959 su padre vicente
murió momento en el que a solá le
compuso un himno a su memoria al amor
que le profesaba adiós nonino
[Música]
[Aplausos]
para finales de la década de 1960 que
asola buscó acercarse a la música
popular
- rupturista - de élites y así logró
embarcarse en 1967 en la ópera tanguera
maría de buenos aires y en 1969 en la
avalada por un loco para la beca de 1970
plazo la cerrada y con italia y formó su
octeto electrónico una música
vanguardista progresista un tango que l
coqueteaba el jazz y al rock
una música del futuro
[Música]
efe
aquí
pero su conjunto electrónico fue
disuelto ante las críticas infundadas de
que aquella música ensordecía y le
aconsejaron volver al quinteto de
regreso en argentina que asola conformó
un segundo quinteto en 1978 con un
trabajo muy intenso de presentaciones y
conciertos era una época de consagración
en la que el mundo entero admiraba su
trabajo aplaudido por su generación y
visto como un virtuoso en 1979 piazzolla
exploró la música sinfónica con obras
como concierto para bandoneón y orquesta
pero muchos expertos criticaron que esta
música erudita pecaba de culta y no era
lo suyo de manera que pasó la retorno al
tango en la década de 1980 con un
segundo quinteto y en 1988 compuso la
camorra su último ensamble para tango
del cual dijo que era la cosa más grande
que había hecho
aquejado por su salud que asola sufrió
un paro cardíaco y después un accidente
cerebrovascular que lo arrastraron hasta
su muerte el 4 de julio de 1992 en
buenos aires el 11 de marzo 2020
no estaría cumpliendo 100 años astor
piazzolla adelantado a su época dijo
alguna vez que tenía una ilusión que su
música se escuchará en el 2020 y en el
3000 también así llegamos al final soy
andrés suárez jaramillo gracias por
compartir estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]